well good ladies Rolanda welcome to
Piers Morgan on censored I took two
weeks off and all hell broke loose but
as usual most of the hell is coming from
Prince Harry's mouth he moved to
California rocking the foundations of
the British Monarchy it was about three
years ago they quit now it seems like
forever doesn't it uh the Clans he's
made this week have detonated a bomb but
this weapons-grade hypocrite has done
nothing more than reduce his own
reputation to rubble and after torching
what's left of the bridges back to his
family he now begins a new personal
Journey we're told one that ends with
ridicule and irrelevance the prince you
fled Britain to protect his family's
privacy has laid bare every tordry
detail of his private life from drug
abuse to intimate conversations with his
father the king even at Prince Philip's
funeral
the daddy fears for the security of his
family apparently has put a Target on
their backs now and on the backs of the
royal family and on his former military
colleagues with his stupid boasts about
killing 25 Taliban was he calls them
chess pieces and the be kind Ambassador
so earnestly invested in women's rights
brags about mocking a disabled matron at
his prep school he names her
she's called Pat he said she was greasy
and too ugly for him to feel horny think
about that woman tonight having to deal
with that in what will be one of the
biggest red books of the year how does
she feel if she's still around I don't
know how to have family feel about that
he also exposes how he lost his
virginity says he mounted some woman
behind a pub and she spanked him on his
ass
he checked that terminology with Meghan
Markle hasn't she just literally done a
podcast series trying to eliminate
sexist terminology from Men
oh dear Harry
the discard his son who just wants
private clear of the air talk to his
family if only he wasn't scared they'd
be leaked has now leaked everything and
I mean everything I read it all today it
is mind-blowing
most outragency of all Harry and Megan
allow claims to swallow about racism in
the royal family for almost two years
they made a six-hour documentary about
it they accepted a human rights award
last month for fighting structural
racism in the royal family all based on
what they told Oprah Winfrey but now
Harry's decided that apparently that's
not what they meant at all
in the Oprah interview you accuse
members of your family of racism you
don't even well of the British press
said that
right I did Megan ever mention the races
she said there were troubling comments
about what she was concern about his
skin color right wouldn't you describe
that as essentially I wasn't not having
lived within that family the way the
British press reacted to that was fairly
typical neither of us believe that that
comment
all that experience
or that opinion was based in racism
I would like to apologize on behalf of
the British press actually because he is
an unbelievable village idiot and I
think it's all our fault honestly it's
not the fact that he was useless at
school and got no qualifications which
is why he's doing all this stupid stuff
it's the British press his foot we're
responsible for everything including his
Ginger hair and I'd like to apologize
for giving him Ginger hair it's awful
you should never have done it
but let me get this straight on a
serious point the racist British press
blamed for six hours straight of that
Netflix bilge for hounding Megan out of
our racist country
driven at the top by a racist royal
family
apparently it's the press That's to
blame
for saying that Meghan markle's claims
of racism were claims of racism
now this had consequences what they said
to Oprah Winfrey I was forced out of my
last job presenting Good Morning Britain
a job I really enjoyed because I said I
didn't believe these claims without firm
evidence
there wasn't any and now we get told it
wasn't racism exactly it's what I
suspected at the time do I get an
apology
to Sharon Osborne one of my guests
tonight does she get restored to her job
at the CBS show the talk because she got
fired for offering support on Twitter
for my right to my opinion because
apparently I'd said racist things it
turned out those racist things were not
believing Meghan markle's racism claims
now they say they didn't mean racism so
does Sharon get her job back
will they give back that award that they
got for the heroic battle against
structural racism in the royal family
now we know there was no racism
structural or otherwise
across three new interviews and 416
whining pages of his book spare me as I
call it Harry lambast the British press
and his family for colluding with the
British press is bitterness and bile for
Camilla the queen consort is shocking
this is the love of his father's life
who he Brands a dangerous villain
how was she dangerous because of the
need for her to rehabilitate her image
that made her dangerous that made her
dangerous because of the connections
that she was forging within the British
press and there was
open willingness on both sides to trade
of information and with a family built
on hierarchy and with her on the way to
being Queen consort there was going to
be people or bodies left in the street
because of that
bodies left in the street there's a guy
who boasted about killing 25 Taliban
actual bodies that he left in the street
and then boasted about it which is now
enraged the entire Muslim world but
Camilla was apparently dangerous because
she forged relationships with the media
says the man who's pocketed over a
hundred million dollars by forging
relationships with media entities like
Netflix Spotify Oprah Winfrey James
Corden CBS ABC And So It Goes On
he says his brother the Prince of Wales
attacked him because he was riled by
reading stories and metabloids but also
that his brother placed those stories in
metabloids himself he slams a memoir by
Diana's Butler Paul Burrell as one man's
self-justifying self-centering version
of events my God the irony of this
from a man who's literally just produced
these single most self-justifying
centering self-centering version of
event imaginable
and if we want any more evidence of
Harry's complete loss of self-awareness
and utter delusion it's surely in that
claim that the book the book was never
intended to do any harm or hurt to his
family
you said you want your father and
brother back do you think that this book
is going to bring them back or are they
going to further divide you I have
thought about it long and hard and as
far as I see it the devoid couldn't be
greater
before this book but I genuinely believe
that if me and my family can reconcile
can put our differences behind us but
first there needs to be conversation and
accountability and if that doesn't
happen then that's very sad
compensation and accountability is that
a joke
is that a joke you're the one doing all
the attacking you're the bully you're
the one trashing your family in public
not the family that stayed silent
throughout this Onslaught has been going
on now for several years
what's sad Harry is your public
self-destruction and the remorseless way
you've Savaged your own loved ones to
airbrush yourself
please don't make my final days of
misery King Charles said to Harry after
Prince Philip's Memorial we know that
because Harry's told us he's revealed
that most excruciatingly private
conversation with his father our new
king
imagine what he would have said if a
tabloid newspaper had revealed that
conversation it's disgusting
and his privacy this proves what I say
about you more you're revolting yeah
maybe but what does it make you now
you've done exactly the same thing that
you've been ranting about for years
Harry and Megan just be clear
have sold their Royal souls for a life
as reality stars trading every private
cough and splutter for cash
the royal family has said nothing about
this volley of abuse it's maintained a
dignified silence which I think is a
correct response because without the
Royal gravitas without the titles Harry
and Megan well what are they they're
just another version of the Kardashians
they've gone for broke with this ladies
installment of the only way is Sussex
but we might finally be closing in
hopefully on the final episode
well joining me in the studios talk TV
presenters Sharon Osborne Vanity Fair
role as a Katie Nicole from New York
talk TV's Tricia Goddard and Princess
Diana's former Butler Paul Burrell so a
stellar lineup to discuss all this Paul
Bowen let me start with you you like
most people uh get a kicking in the book
he dismisses you as self-serving writing
a book just to put one side of the of
the point of view I mean I had to laugh
when I read that this is by a guy who's
literally just done exactly that
yes it appears you knew my story at the
time I was being Trashed by everyone and
I went to the highest court in the land
and I had to survive I had to feed my
family I would everything I had was
taken away from me Harry's in a totally
different position he's an angry
petulant privileged prince who
constantly blames others for with no
accountability on his part his mother
would be absolutely appalled by don't
only Ant-Man himself he's undermining
his country his family the institution
which is the monarchy which his mother
was very proud of
um Beggar's belief I don't recognize the
young man that I grew up with I don't
recognize that man anymore I I just
don't know what's happened to him I
think he's lost the plot completely
appears this book shouldn't be called
Sperry it should be called blame because
he's blaming everybody else but himself
yeah I completely agree and also I've
never seen an unhappier looking person
who constantly tells us how happy he is
this is not a happy man he's bitter
bitter bitter no and there seems to be
no end to the bitterness
no and you have to remember our dearly
Queen had to suffer this too before she
died because she also watched the Oprah
Winfrey interview and and thought what
on Earth is happening here why didn't
Harry come and talk to me about this so
she went to her grave actually not
knowing the truth with great distress
which Harry compounded in her final days
of her life well I think she I honestly
think the queen will be turning in a
grave reading all this stuff and reading
the Fallout
um because not not only did that Oprah
Winfrey interview air literally a couple
of days after Philip was taken to
hospital and as we later know died
within several months but the book has
now come out within three months of the
queen dying and there is his response to
the death of our great Monarch is within
three months to do a book which causes
severe damage to the institution that
she represented so magnificently for
over 70 years
I
I totally agree and Piers you remember
those boys growing up you saw them grow
you came to Ken's the palace out in
those days Diana always had the final
word so I'm going to leave you with my
my words which I think Diana would be
saying right now she'd be saying to
Harry jumping up and down wanted to be
noticed
Harry be quiet
now you do wonder who on Earth is having
that conversation with him what's good
attrition God I said Trisha you know you
were there on Good Morning Britain on
the day the uh well the morning after
the Oprah Winfrey interview air we had a
pretty Lively series of exchanges on
that show as you know I left Good
Morning Britain the next day because I
uh was asked to apologize for
disbelieving her claims of racism I said
I wanted to see evidence of this
so-called racism we now learn from
Harry's own mouth that they did not call
the royal family races after all uh so
I'm not quite sure why I had to leave my
job are you
yes
um because they actually didn't use the
words racist oh please and
would you like me to finish no I tell
you what I want to do Trisha before you
go any further I want to play you what
they said on Oprah then you can repeat
what you've just said let's watch this
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what about
how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like what was that conversation
that conversation I'm never going to
share
um but at the time
at the time it was awkward I was a bit
shocked
yeah and the end of that first clip of
Meghan Markle goes on to say that if the
baby was too dark that would be a
problem yes you may think that so that
that I'm afraid that is racism
the charge was racism against the royal
family at the time they produced no
evidence her version of events was
nearly two years after Harry's timeline
when this happened they've never named
The Royal member who said this stuff and
now we get told casually it's not racism
all right can you just play that again
because there must be something wrong at
my line I didn't hear either Harry or
Megan use the word racism I heard you
use it I saw the Press use it I didn't
actually hear them use the word and
that's what when we had that a robust
exchange of of words I think what I said
to you is that I do get fed up with
other people labeling white people
labeling what is and isn't racist to to
black people now if they'd actually use
the word racism
honestly this is utterly ridiculous so
what is racism I'll tell you what racism
is I'll tell you what racism
I know I'm white Morgan's about to
lecture a black woman about racism
racism I'm about to give you an example
of racism as a middle-aged white man who
I know is right the enemy to you because
you know let me tell you one example
racism is an example of racism would be
somebody expressing concern about the
skin color of a baby from a mixed race
marriage and when the when the
interviewer then says what if it was
darker that would be a problem yes you
may think that that is an example of
somebody expressing racism and that
became the headline and narrative for
the next two years after the interview
and for you to shamelessly sit there and
pretend that wasn't what they meant is
utter bilge if there were more black
people in the media in the you know in
the Tabloid media they may have had the
opportunity to look into that and
explain it a little bit more I didn't
see it as racism I saw it and that's why
I got crossed when you you decided to
label it later I didn't decide to do
anything I well in that when we were
happy they literally confirmed Oprah
Winfrey but a member
attempts to talk about this in other
than headline news when I'm trying to
have a recent conversation I get shouted
over why is my experience or what black
people experience why do we have no
currency why uh they've literally had
front pages about the racist royal
family for two years how much more does
Meghan Markle one has no one has called
the the royal family racist I mean I I
forgot
I would say it's built on built on the
Commonwealth and we already know Charles
has had problems you know they've talked
about the crown that Camilla may or may
not use because the the history of one
of the Diamonds the Korean or diamonds
and what have you we know that the
royalty and many royal families around
the world were built on the backs of
slavery racism commonwealth countries
having good stolen or or taken away from
that we know that unfortunately it's not
taught in school sorry
the history is racism
great respect to you you can't just keep
talking I'm allowed to ask questions
it's an interview right my question for
you you're not allowed to make
statements right without listening to
what somebody says Meghan Markle made a
direct charge supported by her husband
that a member of the royal family had
expressed concern about the potential
skin color of their baby which if it was
too dark would be a problem that is
racism they made a charge yes that's
called racism yeah if you think that if
a baby's too dark it's a problem that's
called racism sorry to have to lecture
you about racism I know I'm not allowed
to as a white man but actually that is
an example of racism
tell us about my history tell us about
the history of black people and what
rate what's that got to do with what
they said
because they didn't say it was racist
yes they did somebody else used that
word they stepped aside from using that
word I think very deliberately why did
they win an award tell us about
unconscious why do they tell us about
unconscious bias I'll tell you about
unconscious delusion which is they won
an award bias what does it mean I do the
questions you do the answering it's
called an interview show right and it's
before Christmas they accepted an award
for their heroic heroic stand against
the structural racism of this royal
family based on what they told Oprah
Winfrey that was all a complete lie
there was no racism we now know they
never meant to say it was racism you're
supporting them that was never meant to
be racism queering the color of a baby
from a mixed race marriage and
expressing concern if it was going to be
too dark it's not racism Trish you take
me for a complete mug it couldn't be a
clearer example of racism why deny it
really yeah no
so so am I right in thinking that you
know better than you you I have no idea
of what racism is I don't say that I
didn't say that I said to you very
clearly I'm sorry that you you sorry
what do you keep doing you keep putting
words into my mouth I'm not actually
saying and the viewers aren't stupid
they can hear the conversation with them
they didn't use you want people to
believe that actually what she said
Meghan Markle to Oprah Winfrey supported
by Harry does not constitute racism and
I'm afraid no I said it's unconscious
but I think you are being deliberately
either delusional or disingenuous which
one is it
you haven't explained what you
understand by unconscious bias so I'm
not quite sure you're not doing the
interview
no I don't care sorry we've now moved
from racism to unconscious bias right I
would like to move to unconscious or
conscious delusion right because we all
know what she said to Oprah Winfrey we
all know that for the last two years the
royal family has been reeling from the
charge of being racist because one of
their senior members expressed concern
over the skin color of their unborn baby
and now we get told casually by Harry
clearly feeling a bit of remorse about
what's gone down here because I read the
whole book today this story doesn't
appear in the book this allegation of
racism isn't in there why where is it
gone why nor is he nor is the allegation
where Meghan Markle which is the other
thing I queried at the time before I had
to leave the building I also said where
is the proof that she went to somebody
at Buckingham Palace about her suicidal
thoughts and was told she couldn't get
help that's not in the book either
where's that gone and by the way what
happened to him at the same time when
his brother allegedly attacked him he
called his therapist who was on speed
dial why couldn't he do that for his
wife